we just had that conversation with
Pamela Anderson about Julian Assange and
Vladimir Putin both of whom she knows
but she wouldn't have guessed that
but then the conversation turned to the
taxi services uber and lyft both have
proved popular with the public Pamela
Anderson is not a fan
she is campaigning against ride-sharing
apps she says they exploit their drivers
and endanger passengers watch this you
almost never hear that complaint the
luring drivers and exploit them tell us
what you mean I know everybody knows
about the difficulties that they're
experiencing people are being sexually
assaulted that's common knowledge and
it's being exposed everywhere but also
the drivers are being exploited they are
hired as kind of third-party providers
so the uber is not taking responsibility
for any of their wrongdoings and but
also they're not receiving health care
or any of the things that they should be
receiving as employees wait I'm confused
though because the people who run over
for example are very socially conscious
they're progressive they're they're
obviously very good people they say
they're very good people and they're
also incredibly rich why would they pay
for their health care for the drivers I
don't exactly exactly that's what we're
fighting for is to have that for them
because that will also you'll be able to
get better quality drivers more more
qualified drivers and when people have
you know real benefits and minimum wage
even but I don't understand why nobody
says anything about this
if a factory were paying people what
uber pays per hour and not paying for
their health care when Walmart did it
people jumped up and down and said this
is exploitation but for some reason it
gets a pass why well you know this is
it's this technology it's evolution we
have to right the wrongs and I say you
know if you're a sexual offender you can
probably get a job at uber you can
probably an over driver no no I mean I'm
not for these right apps because it's a
false sense of security you you know my
father used to always you know would
pick me up at night and we send these
strangers to go pick up our our children
and you know maybe a late night
or drinking too much and and you know
instead of it's just a false sense of
security because it's an app that it's
safe and it's not safe it still has bugs
to be worked out and it also needs to
protect and supply you know proper
proper payment to these drivers anybody
can be an OPA driver and it's they have
to fine-tune that so were you saying
that the the billionaires who run over
are so greedy that they won't take
responsibility for their own employees
won't even admit they are employees well
I think that people are finding all
these loopholes they have to tighten it
up it's new you know so it's it's and
it's and it's sad that a lot of people
are being affected like this the actual
employees the drivers and you know the
drivers are the core of the business so
they can't get around that it's the
beauty of cable news you never know what
you're going to hear